next year America goes to the polls
Donald Trump is running for president
while under criminal indictment this the
man who back in 2016 consistently Clues
You of law breaking and actively
encouraged chance of lock her up
directed at you it's pretty ironic isn't
it that he is now a former president
that could face a jail term how does it
make you feel well I always thought
about him and if you follow him uh I
think you can see it as well he accuses
people of doing things he himself is
doing it's a a form of psychological
projection and I always thought that his
record in business in particular but
then as we saw him uh in politics and
government uh he was someone who cared
nothing about rules he cared nothing
about the law so he has been indicted
and there may be others as well but he
has said he's going to keep running and
there's nothing in our current system of
laws that would prevent him from running
but even if he gets the Republican
nomination he cannot in my view be
re-elected uh president
why can't he be re-elected because I
think it's a nomination I think people
are
more people are on to him and his uh
Behavior than they were before he has a
hardcore of support that is likely to
help him win the Republican nomination
but in a general election against
President Biden I do not believe he can
win so you don't think he can win do you
think he's a bigger threat to Biden than
DeSantis
it's hard to tell I mean DeSantis is
unproven nobody really outside of
Florida knows very much about him and in
Florida they're watching him do crazy
things so I I actually believe that
President Biden will be re-elected
regardless of who the Republican nominee
is do you ever worry that President
Biden he will be in his 80s in a second
term isn't too old for the job I feel
like I could do the job I'm in you know
my mid-70s yeah well you might could run
in 2028 well I doubt that but I think uh
it really should be a matter of what he
has done as president and pulling
together
um the transatlantic Alliance to support
Ukraine pulling together countries in
Asia to begin to stand up to uh Chinese
uh aggressiveness passing major
legislation through the Congress I think
he has a remarkable record and we're
living though Beth in a time when a lot
of people expect their leaders to be
performers not Purdue juicers yes and so
is he a performer as we think of maybe
one of your prior Prime Ministers or one
of our prior presidents no that's not
who he is and thank God for that because
look at what he's getting done